meantime we've been talking for days and
weeks about Tropicana it's here right
now in Arkansas is live over at trop and
Dean Martin kind of Where The Heart of
the action is so fill us into what's
happening now and what's coming later
this week Candace
good morning good morning folks yes I'm
exactly where all the action is we got
another six days you guys of this area
being closed here on Tropicana Dean
Martin all the way down to New York New
York as you can see the work is underway
on the I-15 interchange and the bridge
there folks have been coming this way a
little confused even though we've been
telling people about it so people have
kind of been stopping even though
there's cones all the way down to
Polaris here right before you hit Dean
Martin but folks have kind of been
trying to navigate around which way to
go of course either going right and left
and going around to get back over on the
other side here is probably the best
thing to do as we mentioned the
southbound I-15 ramp closer to Tropicana
kicked off this project last Tuesday and
this thing tends to upgrade the I-15
shop again interchange by rebuilding the
intersection and the Tropicana Avenue
Bridge over I-15 we'll get an extra Lane
here on shrop and pedestrian upgrades
including walkways on the multi-year
project includes closers to the east
tropagana ramp for nine months and West
for 18 but the biggest impact could be
that closer on the I-15 in both
directions from Russell to Flamingo this
Friday the 27th all the way till Monday
and then it'll go down to two lanes
after that
it's been suggested to either get off on
Russell and Flamingo but they've kind of
been giving you some Insider tips of
this morning and letting you know that
you could also go on a detour at Desert
Inn Harman Hacienda those are just some
extra ones you go ahead and try out
there and of course we'll be with you
along the way showing you conditions on
the roll you can see here now it's
starting to brighten up people are
starting to get on their way to work
something school is closed today so
maybe they'll be a little less traffic
but again we will have details for you
on our website newsnow.com and of course
you can go to the I-15 trop app or
i15trop.com for visuals detours and all
of that good stuff we've been advised to
tell you folks to use the Waze app and
that has worked with them too is secure
the GPS details and detours for you on
that app as well again we have details
for you on website newsnow.com for now
live from Tropicana and Dean Martin I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now